hello everyone I don't really show games
between two engines on my channel but i
don't i don't consider alpha zero to be
an engine that uses route force
you know it's thought itself to play
chess in four hours so i'm sure very
soon he will be a valuable member of the
chess community so this is a one of the
games played between deepmind and stock
fish and people are saying that you know
it's not the latest version of stock
fishing that alpha zero was run on a
much more powerful computer but still
you know it had four hours maybe maybe
give it like two days and then you know
organize a match would be all-knowing
and all-powerful top tier stock fish so
that would be an interesting event as
well and you know putin is the probably
already writing a big check to deepmind
to acquire this alpha zero thingy to
prepare Kerrigan for the candidates
that's you know it would be amazing you
know what what chess players could do
having alpha zero to prepare them you
know it would probably completely change
the way chess is played but you know we
can only speculate for now we'll just
we'll just see where this goes so this
is a one other game I chose it's it's
the same variation as in the previous
game but with one different move from
stock fish that changes the course of
the game so let's see it we have Knight
to f3 Knight f6 b4e 6 + c4 and b6 again
we have the Queen's Indian defense g3
Bishop to b7 Bishop to g2 all the same
as in the previous game there should be
seven of 0 Castle starfish castles d5
eat after Sun d5 and now Knight to h4
again the same as in the previous game
c6 see capture Sun d5 Knight capture son
d5 and ninth to f5
nice to see 7 now getting that night out
of the way all the same as in the
previous game and E 4 and here stockfish
takes a different approach instead of
playing
to have six like in the previous game
after Knight to d6 and attacking this
Bishop on b7 stockfish really got into a
terrible position
so after E 4 D 5 now and does the seem
like more it seems like a more human
move to me but you know it's better than
keep your pawn stranded on b7
so in chapters on d5 Knight captures on
d5 and Knight to c3
stockfish captures the knight Knight
captures on c3 and not be captures on c3
but Queen to g4 by alpha zero already
threatening checkmate on g7 g6
night to h6 with Czech king to H then it
came to g7 and the only now B captures
unsee to me stalkerish plays better to
c8 would attempt on the Queen Queen to
f4 now and Queen to d6 wanting to
exchange Queens now Queen to a4 g5 and
here stockfish is now threatening to
capture the night as the bishop is no
longer protecting it and white I mean
alpha 0 could go for something like
Knight g4 and after f5 93 but you know
it's it seems ok for black from my
perspective but instead after g5 it
doesn't retreat the night instead alpha
zero plays rook to e1 it gives up the
night on h6 King captures on h6 and h4
and already you can see a lot of
similarities from the previous game I've
shown you this rook and the night are
not getting into the game as alpha zero
is not allowing it f6 now and the Bishop
to e3 Bishop to f5 and now rotate to the
one would attempt on the Queen Queen to
a3 stockfish again wants to exchange
Queens Queen to see for now and b5 we
have 8 crackers on g5 would check F
captures on g5 and Queen to h4 check now
as the g5 pawn is pinned
king to g6 and here
have a great move alpha zero plays Queen
- h1 and what's the idea here the idea
here is that it's very hard to find a
move for black you can't really improve
on the position and you can't develop
any of these pieces if you try and get
the night into the game for example with
Knight to d7 you don't capture the pawn
here or or anything like that but you
play g4 and now if Bishop captures on g4
then you have Bishop to g4 check Bishop
blocks and now rook captures on d7 you
just lost the piece and I mean and
you're still getting attacked
so alpha zero wins the piece back
so after g4 you'd have to go for
probably something like Bishop to e6 but
now you're getting checkmated and now
Bishop to g4
you have to block this or you get Queen
captures on h7 so I have to rip the f5
captures captures captures and something
like King to f7 Queen captures on h7
check King g8 and Bishop captures and g5
the rook to Bishop to Queen are all
eyeing that East 7 Bishop there is no
defense against this you're getting
checkmated so after Queen to h1 King to
g7 I was now played we have Bishop to e4
better back to g6 Bishop captures H
captures and now Queen to h3 with some
ideas of bringing the Queen 3-6 also the
queen is adding more pressure to d7
square and if you play something like
knife to a6 to try and develop again you
lose the roof to d7 now this Bishop is
being Bishop to b4 is coming and this
will be terrible this will be also black
is getting checkmated so after Queen to
h3 Bishop to f6 getting the Bishop out
of the way and King to g2 now making
room for this rook to come to h1 Queen
captures on a - and now rook to h1 we
have Queen to g8 going back to the
defense the threat was Queen to h7
checkmate
c4 now
if black captures it would only ruin
it's a bone structure so rook to e8
instead we have Bishop to d4 Bishop
captures rook captures and rook to d8
starfish wants to exchange works but
capture sandy 18 capture sandy eight and
we have Queen to e6 and it's again
Europe piece but like in the previous
game starfish can't develop even neither
this rook or the night and maybe maybe
the alpha zero is telling us something
here about the Queen's Indian defense so
here
Knight to d7 was played by stockfish and
this is met with rook to d1 but it
doesn't matter if Knight to a6 is played
then Queen to e5 wins the game
immediately if you play Queen f6 and
then Rock to h7 wins the Queen and if
play something like King to g8 then
rotate rate check King f7 work h7 check
King f8 and between h8 this is checkmate
so after Queen to e6 Knight to d7 was
played rook to d1 now pinning the knife
there's nothing I can do here tonight
the c5 now with the temple on White
Queen
but rook captures Knight captures and
the rook captures rook and now stock
fish is up two pawns but again he's down
the exchange like in the previous game
and this is easily winning for white so
we'll just show how the endgame went I
mean it's a and and hey I accidentally
said in my previous video that stock
fish was probably rated somewhere around
2400 of course I meant the 3400 not 2400
so g4 and f3 we have here in 9f 7 the
rook is simply too powerful he's gonna
gobble up all of the pawns and here
after this King to d4 move and it's very
satisfying to say this next sentence in
this position stockfish resigned the
game this is something you probably
never hear I mean whenever you've heard
something like this you should try
saying it it's it's very satisfying so
yeah that's the game that
that's alpha zero for you and I'm very
happy I'm very you know looking forward
to seeing where this goes and will will
they continue you know feeding alpha
zero not feeding him but allowing him to
learn even more okay now he's learning
chess but you know using this algorithm
I'm sure he can learn pretty much
anything maybe even and maybe it can
even teach Matt and Max Deutsch how to
defeat Magnus Carlsen in one month so
yeah I would like to thank alone and
Alan Barrett for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here the upper
left game will be the other game played
by alpha zero and yeah thank you for
watching I will see you soon